back now at 7 30 here on CBS mornings
and the midterms are less than three
weeks away every vote counts but there
are blocks of Voters that really could
sway things we wanted to understand them
more and to help us we are joined Now by
Face the Nation moderator Margaret
Brennan and CBS News elections and
surveys director Anthony salvanto uh
okay guys so there are these groups that
you've termed election influencers uh
they include if I have this right
pressured parents
Trump True Believers restoring Roe
voters and The Young and Restless no
relation to the show
Anthony starting with you what can you
tell us about these four groups you've
isolated we want to understand the
election through the motivations of the
people who are participating in it and
get away from the usual labels
demographic labels party labels we have
interviewed so many voters through the
course of our CBS News polling this is
what emerged from that data as people
tell us this is how they process this
campaign so we want to bring you that
okay so tell us can you just give us a
tick tock on each one of them pressured
parents Mains indeed pressured parents
are people who were dealing with covid
and reported that they felt stress about
that and their kids and now they're
facing Financial pressure after
inflation on top of that that's where we
start and that group is somewhat closely
divided leading a little bit more
Republican right now but it's those dual
pressures that really Define that Trump
True Believers Trump True Believers are
people who consider themselves Mega
Republicans and they don't like the
direction of the country they want the
party to be loyal to the former
president and they're really the center
of gravity in the Republicans history
simply single issue voters on abortion
these women say that is what is
motivating them and my favorite category
not related to the show is Tony pointed
out the Young and the Restless Young and
the Restless I call this this is a
turnout story for the Aegis which is to
say they're not the largest group in the
electorate but they could really matter
if they show up 130 no kids and Margaret
you spent some time with people in the
pressured parents group what'd you learn
yes we've been digging into a lot of
these topics and this is one of the most
powerful focus groups we did getting
parents to talk about what they've been
through and the collective trauma of
covid is with us now it's in the Mental
Health crisis this mother telling us
about her 12 year old running out of the
house screaming like a three-year-old
having a meltdown a dad talking to us
about depression we are just starting to
kind of measure what it's done to us
mental health also you can measure it in
the education crisis reading level
decline for nine-year-olds at uh has
declined by the largest margin in more
than 30 years according to the education
department a hundred thousand caregivers
gone and then the cost you pay has gone
up there are very real stresses and
we've seen this erupt politically in
school board meetings getting violent
over what's even taught in the classroom
the lack of control is powerful we saw
Republicans harness it in the state of
Virginia when it came to that election
last year to elect a governor where
education was put at the centerpiece of
it so we're watching how these voters
Define themselves because it's kovitz
redefined us of course now one of the
groups that we hear most about is the
Trump True Believers why is it important
to understand their perspective and
don't we kind of know how they're going
to vote or the perception of how they
will vote we absolutely know how they're
going to vote they're voting for
Republicans but what makes them
important two things one is when you see
Republican candidates talking about
election denialism talking about being
loyal to the former president they know
that they need the votes of these folks
so that helps you understand The
Narrative of the campaign and who
they're talking to and who they're
talking to even though for the rest of
Voters we know that the foreign
president is a net negative so it's very
much about turnout for a lot of these
groups and then you ask yourself well if
those candidates moderate their stances
at all do some of these folks stay home
and people get caught up in in hearings
you know certain narratives they say
Well they're isolating many of us but
it's not that they're isolating many of
us they are speaking to their core
audience exactly
uh Margaret uh the uh the Roe voters
that we've isolated uh what kind of an
influence could they have are they going
to turn out in the numbers that
Democrats are hoping they will well
Anthony's been tracking that very
carefully and on Sunday space the nation
talked about the momentum stalling for
Democrats on the back of what had been a
really uh engaging momentum for them but
what we've seen is that for the this
midterm election it's not just a
referendum on the president and his
party this issue is literally on the
ballot in at least five states so when
we talk about turnout that could matter
that could be an influence there and
when you look at what happened back in
August if you remember in the
traditionally conservative state of
Kansas people were surprised when the
overwhelming vote was to hold on to
abortion access so this is a new Dynamic
and for years abortion had been and you
could speak to that as well that a
single issue voter
platform for the other side and so now
Democrats are hoping and you heard
President Biden just yesterday come out
and say his first legislative priority
in a new Congress if Democrats win will
be trying to create a law to protect
abortion access something that hadn't
been done in 50 years they're trying to
motivate people to turn out 20 days in
counting for the election it's going to
be a long night for all of us long night
long week and making this information
digestible thank you so much Margaret
Brennan and Anthony silvanto thank you
thank you